(hip hop music)
- Many more people should
be leaving their jobs.
(hip hop music)
Go do your thing.
You're gonna die.
Is it your mom?
Is it society?
Is it your partner?
Why are you not willing
to take one step backwards
for a step for the rest of your life?
How many people by show of hands
work in a job and are
desperate for their side hustle
to become their career?
Just raise your hands.
So many of you created
golden handcuffs for yourself
that aren't letting you leave your job
because you need to
make $130,000 a year now
'cause you wanted 700 more
square feet in your apartment
or you wanted a BMW instead of a Toyota.
(upbeat music)
Something I've realized that really kinda
caught me off guard is how many people
spend more money on shit
than they can afford.
The fact that 30-fuckin'-five
percent of this audience
wants their side hustle
to be their careers
but the reason they can't
is 'cause they can't quit their job
'cause they need their
job to pay for dumb shit
to impress people they fuckin' hate.
And so, you're not
happy because you wanted
two or three things that
mean absolutely nothing.
Why are you not willing
to take one step backwards
for a step for the rest of your life?
The amount of people that have emailed me
in the last six months because
I've been on this rant lately
of trying to get people to
move back in with their parents
at 30 and 40.
You're worried about if you
move back in with your parents,
or if you're not married with a job at 31,
if you are not willing
to take a step backwards,
a step backwards, which
then affords you the ability
to quit your bullshit job
or stop doing your bullshit start-up
and do something else you love
or you think you can be good at.
Like who the hell's
permission are you looking for
to do your thing?
Like who is this person?
Is it your mom?
Is it society?
Is it your partner?
Is it the people that are
commenting in your social media?
Is it something that happened
to you when you were nine?
If your pessimistic mom is gonna be like
see, I told you you could never do it,
if you can't get over that,
then you're fuckin' stuck.
(inspiring music)
Go do your thing.
You're gonna die.
It's going to end.
Something bad is gonna happen.
Something great is gonna happen.
But most of all, nothing's gonna happen
unless you do something.
Please, stop looking for permission.
Please go do that thing you wanted to do.
Ask that person out.
Start that company.
Quit that fuckin' bullshit job.
You can always get another bullshit job.
How are you not willing
to take a step backward
because of other people's opinions
and willing to ruin the
next 47 years of your life?
Take a fucking step backwards
to take a step forward
for the rest of your life.
(inspiring music)